did you think you
make
I'm Victory I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to ha
Romie look what I become
the okay so episode number 352 today
home team a bunch of Stories We got a
man update to see what's going on there
we got to find last night we had dinner
it was pretty heated I don't want to
tell them what happened the fight that
broke that I don't want to get into that
but it was pretty heated so bunch of
crazy stories pulling one melay from
Argentina gave a speech after being
introduced by Claus Schwab and you have
to see how he opens it up in the first
minute it's a 23 minute speech we're not
going to watch the whole thing we'll
watch the first minute later on I highly
recommend you go watch it WF is saying a
bunch of different things while they're
together right now uh n which it stands
for natural asset companies which means
uh uh they can they can buy and own your
air in your area you can own the land
but they own the air it's a lot of
different things that they're pitching
New York City stock today's the last day
for people to talk and try to get rid of
it to make their voices heard then there
was a video clip from Jamie Diamond
Jamie Diamond said something that even
the hosts that were listening to him
were like uh why is the most powerful
guy in banking saying what he's saying
right now about Trump wait till you hear
this I'll play this clip for you CJ
Stout who just won a game for the
Houston uh uh Texans Texans and uh you
know when he won the game afterwards in
the interview you have to hear how ABC
edited what he said in a postgame
interview for the world not to see what
do you think they cut out don't say
anything we play a clip for you and show
you both of them then there's Ohio Ohio
uh in certain areas came up with a
permit free carry of guns you have to
see what happens to the city with the
different stats Oh weird California lost
Tom has numbers from last night on what
happened to California after all the
people decided to leave California to
other places then at the same time we're
going to talk about the story on how
Russia Iran and China are making moves
that could trigger World War III Bill
Amman warns Democrats after Landslide
Iowa caucus win that Trump is going to
crush Biden is he delusional does he
know what he's talking about we'll talk
about that depopulation could make over
half of us City ghost towns by 2100 top
Pharma coo says preparedness for a new
pandemic has not
improved then we have Red Sea risk to
oil
very real prices could change rapidly if
supplies disrupted says Chevron CEO
Chinese scientists create Co strain with
100% kill rate in mice as you just wake
up one day you're like you know what
guys why don't we build something that's
got a 100% kill rate why would you build
that let because we have time on our
hands that's what these Chinese
scientists did white black Hispanic and
asian-americans are all back death of
Dei poll all back death of the pole
which we'll show you what that means
here in a minute Nikki Haley under
pressure from donors to defeat Donald
Trump in New Hampshire after Iowa caucus
loss Bernie Sanders to vote freeze a to
Israel us puts hotties back on the
terrorist list and US carries out
additional strikes against htis in Yemen
and then last but not least the bill is
coming due on a record amount of
commercial real estate debt which we
will discuss and then maybe a couple of
stories if we have anytime left but with
that being said look the most important
election going on on pbd podcast is the
race to 500 on man and and I want you
because tonight today Adam has a speech
that he wants to give to everybody so
does Vinnie everybody knows last time
Vinnie said it 100 plus of you within 24
hours maned with Vinnie love you guys
this is what the score looks like right
now at the top Vinnie was I believe last
place he went to second place he's
officially taking the throne from Tom
and here's what the scores look like we
did it Vinnie's at 307 with only 193
left to 500 to win the suit come on guys
again Tom is at 275 with a massive
support behind him they're not letting
up there's a group that wants to help
Tom out and Adams at 179 he's convinced
still not by the way he's not giving up
or anything he's convinced he's still
going to pull it off and win so with
that being said with Man by the way we
got a bunch of other people that just
joined man in the last couple days Brian
Ken officially got on
bunch of different there's a couple guys
that are coming up climbing climbing 10
20 30 40 minut in no time I I love what
this app is doing questions that come up
that you can actually get a respond back
from somebody when you DM them ask them
a question I believe when people say how
come nobody responds back when I DM
someone because they value their time on
Manet what you get to do is to say
listen expert listen influencer listen
somebody that I want to ask you a
question I saw value your time that I'm
willing to pay to get a respond back on
a text on a video or a FaceTime phone
call with you I believe your 15 minutes
are worth this I'm willing to conect
with you so with this race being this
close Vinnie 307 275 179 Tom do you have
anything to say to your supporters well
first of all thank you for your
questions I get a lot of great questions
about career about job I got a small
business this is what I'm doing I really
appreciate answering them my answer all
of them and you'll notice a lot of them
I will answer in voice text I'm starting
to use voice text more so you'll hear my
voice you know it's me it is really me I
give you all these answers permanently
no Bots no chat gbt no assistant doing
it you are getting it back from me I
thank you so much and so if you've got
questions job career small business how
do I finance this a couple of great
questions have been like on hey do I
start my own business or I keep earning
you know money now and we've gone back
and forth a couple questions just
leaving people then I found them thank
you for your support and if you send
your questions in remember it's only $24
in the first quarter of this year 2024
for toown for 2024 and I'll answer a
question for you age before Beauty go
ahead go go ahead rock paper scissors
give a chance they're going Ro I have
one competition that's going and that's
to get to 500 but rock paper scissor to
see who goes next Rambo no no everyone's
waiting no they could they go wait Adam
he's in the lead I'm in the lead
actually okay you know what he is in the
lead in this very specific contest yeah
but I'm in the lead overall
congratulations okay no so like I get it
you're winning this little two we
stretch and I'm proud of you you think
I'm about to go negative I'm about to do
the exact opposite number one for you
guys out there if you haven't downloaded
the app man and you have no clue what
we're talking about take a second
download the app this app is a game
changer okay it is a game changer for
specific advice for whatever you're
looking for your life we are Consultants
we we are coaches we are changing lives
here's what I'll tell you about my
friends Tom and Vinnie if you need
motivation if you need a laugh if you
need positivity of your life this is
your guy this guy is a breath of fresh
air every single day of my life now does
he know all his stuff does he have Rock
for plane sometimes sure but he's a
comedian
WOWT okay hold on I'm not done but I I
genuinely mean I'll be here if you need
me I genuinely mean this for a brain as
positive and as motivational as fun as
it gets Vin oana Tom this guy's a
gentleman let me tell you something
you're getting an absolute bargain of a
deal for $24.99 for this guy to answer
your questions and it's like he should
be genuinely charging a th000 bucks for
what he's doing but he's actually doing
yesterday he was such a gracious guy a
mench he jumped on a call for free with
a buddy of mine a young guy that a
startup entrepreneur I to tell guy tell
him where he was and what his decision
is and how he's been serving actually
I'm not allowed to talk about
but he's but just know that he's doing
some very important stuff if you want
business strategy if you want
fundraising if you want pitch decks
Tom's your guy he's an absolute
gentleman and you know who pbd is a
beast I don't know if you can afford him
but if you can it's worth every penny
but here's what I'll say about you and
why you should consider reaching out to
me and manck I know that we have this
contest and and and I I joked about um
rooting for Vinnie because the guy needs
some new suits and he needs some new
clothes in his life but here's what I'm
most proud about I don't need that's
true I don't need the suit I don't need
to win the contest 30 seconds you're a
seven minute speech here to us it could
have been done if Vinnie did the rock
paper scissors here's what I like by Far
and Away I'm number one in the app
because I sit there and I do 15minute
phone calls with people that are
actually trying to change their lives
I've seen and I've helped 750 people
different people go from ordinary to
extraordinary go from Zero to Hero to go
from average to Savage so if you want to
change your life and upgrade your life
reach out to me on Vinnie wrap it up
Vinnie my fellow Manors dbd podcasters
value tainers first of all I love you
every single one of you okay um and I I
can't say nothing bad about Tom I really
can't say anything yeah you just you got
to get in there but I want to say thank
you for all of you that been messaging
me it's been like a second job for the
past couple days but you know what I'm
going to say and I have nothing negative
to say about Tom and nothing to say
about Adam even though he said I have a
rock in my brain but that rock is
actually a diamond but uh I want you to
ask yourself one question Adam who'd you
vote for this last presidential election
who' you vote for Joe Biden if you want
that person making decisions for your
finances and your life and dating that
don't you dare do it guys man with me we
have how many left I have 200 let's push
guys let's do it today let's be let's
just put this thing to bed and let's
make America conect again let's put the
faces out there the QR code whoever you
want report just go on the code download
the app and you'll go directly to Adam
Vinnie come on baby come on guys let go
get I will give a shout out to the 10
people at the end of the
podcast the first 10 that man me I'm
going to give you a shout out let's go
baby the first hund that maned me I'm
going to give you I'm going to read your
names one by one here let's get do I
have a first story yes we do okay so do
me a favor pull up the Jamie Diamond
clip so here's Jamie Diamond this is a a
man that's running uh you know chase
that you know depending on what numbers
you look at on a daily basis around7
trillion moves with Chase okay money
comes in money goes TR 7 trillion buys
purchases transfers that's a lot of
money you know that this company uh has
influence over and he's on CNBC and look
at the way he breaks down the 2024
election and how the left have been
saying certain things just watch this
and pay very close attention maybe maybe
the most powerful man in the financial
industry today Jamie Diamond go ahead
people are growing they're hungry to
grow they're innovating it's it's
everywhere it's not just Silicon Valley
so we've got this great hand but when
people say Maga they're actually looking
of people voting for Trump and they
think they're voting and they're
basically scapegoating them that you are
like him uh and but I don't think
they're voting for Trump because his
family values if you look just take a
step back be honest he was kind of right
about NATO kind of right about
immigration mhm he grew the economy
quite
well tax reform worked he was right
about some of China I don't I don't like
what he did said China
virus and I don't like how he said
things about Mexico I don't like but he
wasn't wrong about some of these
critical issues and that's why they're
voting for him and and I think people
should be a little more respectful of
our fellow citizens and when you guys
have people up here you should always
ask the why not like it's a binary thing
you're supporting Trump you're not
supporting Trump why are you supporte 5
million of your fellow Americans and
it's I I agree done Democrats done a
pretty good job with the deplorables
hugging on their Bibles and their beer
and their guns I mean really like could
we just stop that stuff and actually
grow up and treat other people with
respect and listen to a little bit you
know we talking
to for one second right there Rob by the
way what this the one thing that popped
out I'm a very I observe I observe a lot
of things look at what pen he's
wearing Ukraine Ukraine pin give me a
break bro you're in the United States a
little bit that's 100% the Ukraine what
is that the Davos pin it's yellow and
it's blue that's a Ukraine pen so Mr 7
million all this money that's the thing
that you're trying to represent is you
know what that's saying War money giving
away I I don't I don't like that it
could also mean anti-authoritarian
regimes like uh Putin it could also mean
that oh yeah the guy that was going to
start World War III and he's in Trump's
pocket I'm just I know I know that
you're a fan of Putin I'm Not Me by the
way by the by the way very good
observation because why wear that when
you can wear the red white and blue the
most beautiful you know you know flag
why didn't you wear that totally get
that but you know where he's at when
he's having this conversation Tom what
do you think about when someone like him
who you know many would say he's
supported presidents on the left you
know and and he's probably not a pro
Trump guy he says something like this
what does this do to money people on
Wall Street forget about what it
influences the average day-to-day person
how about the Wall Street guy that's
like oh my god did you hear what Jamie
did did you hear what Jamie said did you
hear what Jamie said what kind of
influence does he hold and what does he
do Jamie Diamond has consistently been
either a calming force or a rational
Force when you had the interest rates
and they were stepping up up up up up
and everybody was kind of freaking out
Ben beraki what we have eight increases
or whatever it was in one year he was
the calming Force he was the stabilizing
Force when the banks failed remember we
had people forget one year ago we had
Banks failing and we built a special
Federal program to bail him out remember
that it was an emergency program what
was going on Jamie Diamond now was he
opportunistic Tak advantage of that sure
he is but I see a rational force and a
stabilizing force and I hear echoes in
his voice of the things that like Bill
Mars said and the thing that that we saw
John yesterday talking about it and
rolling his eyes leaning back and
talking I think Jamie Diamond hit it on
the head why don't we grow up a little
bit and ask people why they support him
and not make it some binary choice that
you you you endorse all of his family
values I think that is the most eloquent
part of what he said I don't Trump's I
don't support Trump's Family Values but
here here here and here he rationally
and elegantly did it I think he's going
to have a calming force on Wall Street
and I think there's a hedge going on in
that calming voice Adam what do you
think so I think what I think Jamie
Diamond is exactly where I'm at
politically is that we weren't fans of
what was going on in 2015 and 2016 and
what we've also realized is that a large
part of why we weren't fans was because
the media doctoring up what we saw so I
think with everybody you have to evolve
and you have to take in new information
and this guy's what I would call a
rational actor and you're seeing what's
been happening over the last four years
and Biden campaigned on bringing people
together not being so divisive that's
the reason that he beat Trump trump
represented chaos at that time or
perceived chaos but what we' realized
now is that people rational people
people who are reasonable people who are
processed information people that they
have ability to evolve and not cling to
their position say you know what maybe
this guy wasn't as bad as the media made
it out to be maybe he isn't this racist
we all know how watered down racist is a
term these days so someone like jimie
diamond is looking back and saying
listen guys
you MSNBC CNBC NBC mainstream media
you're kind of guilty
so I'm going to be a a gentleman here
and I'm going to actually do what I can
arguably the most powerful man in
finance other than maybe Larry Frink
Black Rock so when he gets on there and
starts semile lecturing the hosts of
MSNBC and directly lectures Hillary
Clinton saying listen the basket of the
pbl comment the clinging to your guns
the clinging to your Bibles guys ask why
do better research dig deeper so I'm
right where Jeremy Jamie Diamond is I
got a score I got a score I want I want
you to give everybody here specifically
Tom I want to start off with you score
everybody moving forward at what
percentage their establishment what
percentage they're non-establishment
okay for example what would you put the
split on Trump what's Trump split on
establishment non-establishment he's
like so he's like 9010 against okay so
90% non-establishment 10% establishment
scored to
santis 6 I would say 7030 yes he is
establishment put Haley oh my God she's
9010 you understand what I'm doing right
now okay so remember nobody is 100 Z
okay non establishment nobody is because
no matter what you have to negotiate
with the establishment okay so you can't
be 100 if you're 100 Zer you're an
anarchist unreasonable you can't so you
don't believe in anything that we're
doing right okay so you know military is
a form of establishment so remember what
I'm saying
here okay so so now here think about
this this
part what score would you give Jamie
Diamond oh very high establishment but a
freeth thinker I would say 80% even
maybe maybe even higher what would you
say Tom in the finance establishment
he's 99 I would say 7030 a part of Jamie
Diamond that I believe is a rational
open market okay Larry think what
percentage is establishment what percent
a not no he's he's he goes the other way
for me more 855 okay perfect so my point
here is this when we're judging these
characters and these individuals you're
not going to get 100% you know he's
wearing a Ukraine pin what are you doing
wearing a Ukraine pin okay I don't agree
with that I don't wear a pin or if
you're going to support a pin wear a
Chase pin CU you're proud of the company
support or guess what wear a America pin
is what you you know you you you support
I'm not a pin guy myself I always forget
the pins I like how come you forgot to
wear I'm like dude I even forget to wear
my own pins for the companies but you
know I wish I was a pin person I forget
a lot of different things I'm pin guide
here
just so you guys and by the way you
always have it on always have it on rock
it puts a u you put a USA pin at times
I'm USA thej the time you stopped
wearing your Ukraine pin like months ago
yes but think about it from this
standpoint moving forward how I would
judge people on what they're saying and
what they're flipping or what their
position of saying what they just said
is go based on is so a 75% establishment
person just said that about meca what
yeah are you kidding so that's the part
that ought to get people to say I would
have never thought he would have said
let's let's face it he was right on NATO
he was right on economy he did good with
this he was right with China I don't
like the fact when he said this he was
right so that's the part where somebody
ought to look at us an establish that
came out of an establishment person's
mouth yeah that guy right there Jamie
diam you know who speaks to he speaks to
every single powerful person in the
establishment every one of them by the
way two days ago I asked a question from
you guys and I've been asking this
question a lot this last week do you
think the phone call is being made where
Jamie Diamond and the establishment Wall
Street guys are calling Trump saying if
you're willing to put Haley as your VP
you're a lock for President we will
publicly support you do you think a
phone call like that is made I believe a
70% chance that phone call is made I
didn't say it's received I said it's
made and they're saying to him we will
come behind you and we'll give you 2300
$400 million and we will go out there
and help raise and we will defend
because we know what you did with the
economy and you were right okay now the
question becomes Will trump entertain
that conversation I believe he will
entertain but I also believe a lot of
the people on the inside that are 100%
supporters to him he's going to bring it
up to him and asked a question that I
believe Trump asks a lot I think Trump
say what do you think guy I think Trump
will say what do you think but he's
going to make the decision what he's
going to he's going to say so what do
you guys think about the phone call we
just got should we consider this do you
agree with them and it's not going to be
asking everybody it's only going to be
asking two three four five people that
he fully trusts with a score of 90 plus
right yeah and I believe a couple of
them are going to say we ought to
entertain it and I believe three out of
five are going to say hell no we
shouldn't entertain it one of the three
I believe is a family member that's
going to say don't do it but I believe
after a message like that that just took
place and we're in the negotiation phase
right now that Tom was talking about two
days ago I think that is a message of
Jamie trying to say hey whisper if you
accept our offer of putting Haley as
your VP I'm going to do more of this
stuff for you I'm just speculating but I
think that's a possibility I think I
think that'd be that's a I wouldn't say
70 I maybe go 60 55% because think about
it and that says a lot when it comes to
that that type of attitude of hey we
want a Haley who's vocally saying that
she just wants war war war her husband's
in the defense Contracting thing pet she
became a millionaire and by the way
coming from a guy that's wearing a pin
that's basically the war sending
billions and sending all this money I
could see how that phone call would
happen I still don't think and I would
lose so much respect for him if Donald
Trump brings in that swamp creature into
his cabinet I I you would 100% still
vote for him though no I wouldn't no you
wouldn't vote for Donald Trump
N I would sit on the
sideline very important I on the
sideline by the way I know what you're
thinking this is very important here yep
because he is a part of a a a a a true
super supporter of what they did to what
the establishment did to him 100% so I
think there's a part the question
becomes behind closed doors what do you
think can I sorry Tom I'm trying to say
something for a few minutes go ahead Tom
yeah so I agreed with you yesterday
yesterday uh day before yesterday that I
think there's 70% chance that the the
call has been made now will it be
received now what I look at is two
things I've been looking at a bunch of
things a bunch of polling data and guess
what happens the closer America gets to
the election the more seriously people
consider the vote it's amazing the
closer we get and in between elections
what do we do great point we stomp our
feet we scream we have Talking Heads
going back and forth each other MSNBC
fox in a in a permanent battle back and
forth across the border were you know
achieving nothing just screaming now it
gets closer who shows up two months ago
we saw it all in pod chamoth he gave
almost the same analysis that Jamie
Diamond did remember that yes he did he
went down now wait a minute guys let's
think about this let's think about this
I was giving him a D minus because what
mainstream media them but if you really
look at it's more like a B+ a minus he
basically gave in his own way on a grade
scale the same thing that he's not a
regular guy this is a guy that's a
billionaire he's made a lot of good
decisions he's a very smart guy very
connected in the in the Silicon Valley
Community and he's only a 50-50 own
establishment because his Investments
are disruptors so he's really only a
50-50 establishment guy so the closer it
gets here the more serious it we get and
now we're seeing and we also have seen
the seriousness of the economy the
seriousness of the world stage the
seriousness of several things and guess
what we're saying huh maybe we do need a
guy like that and we've gotten away from
the screaming and yelling that's what I
think okay all right sounds good let's
go to the next story well can I give 30
seconds cuz 9:31 Story the one thing you
guys need to know about Trump that's
what I was trying to say he's not an
ideologue he's a dealmaker the only
thing that he's an ideologue about is
that America comes first that's it but
he's willing to have any conversation
any phone call he'll go to see Kim
Jong-un he'll go see Putin he'll go see
whoever needs to see to cut a deal and
politics is a numbers game it's a game
of addition not subtraction so he's
looking for addition and you want to
bring people into your tent it's called
a big tent party and nobody's pitching a
bigger tent than the people in Wall
Street these days so he'll gladly take
that money and fix up that phone call so
you think he'll gladly take that money
and make that phone call okay I think he
will take that phone call uh I think the
decisions being May will be very
interesting anyways uh we got we got
three other big stories to get I want to
show you this other clip of as well
before we do let's go into this sponsor
video here with Masterworks go ahead Rob
did you see a recent report that came
back from UBS talking about the fact
that 61% of millionaire collectors put 5
to 30% of their money in Contemporary
Art the last 27 years contemporary art
has outpaced S&P 500 by
136% I can't afford a Banks your a
Picasso one of these incredible Arts I'd
love to have it but I can't do it that's
why today's sponsor is Masterworks which
means securitization has opened a
pathway for the average investor to
invest in art directly from your
smartphone Masterworks allows you to buy
a share and a multi-million dollar
painting and they have $55 Million worth
of art that they've sold they now have
over 880,000 users and over a billion
dollars of assets under management
they've now sold a total of 20 paintings
since 2017 skip the weight list and
invest in Blue Chip art for the very
first time by signing up for Masterworks
go to
masterworks.io he goes to World economic
Forum he's invited and the person that
brings him up on stage is Claus Schwab
and he goes and gives a message
Argentina Z M says the West is in danger
in a fiery Davos speech if you've not
seen the speech it is 23 minutes we're
not going to play the whole three 23
minutes for you but I highly recommend
you make a note and you go watch this
entire thing Rob just play the first
minute minute 20 seconds and listen to
what he says on how Argentina went from
what it was before to what it is today
go ahead
Rob I may have to do a sketch about him
today Pat just let you know you should
he starts off with 10 seconds I don't
think he speaks English it's going to be
all
Spanish good
afternoon thank you very
much today I'm here here to tell you
that the Western world is in
danger and it is endangered because
those who are supposed to have to defend
the values of the West are coopted by a
vision of the world that inexorably
leads to socialism and thereby to
Poverty
unfortunately in recent
decades motivated by some well-meaning
individuals willing to help others and
others motivated by the wish to belong
to a privileged cast the main leaders of
the western world have abandoned the
model of freedom for different versions
of what we call collectivism we're here
to tell you that collectivist
experiments are never the solution to
the problems that afflict the citizens
of the world rather they are the root
cause do believe me no one better place
than us argentines to testify to these
two points when we adopted the model of
Freedom back in 1860 in 35 years we
became a leading world power and when we
Embrace collectivism over the course of
the last 100 years we saw how our
citizens started to become
systematically impoverished and we
dropped to spot
number 140 globally but before having
the discussion it would first be
important for us to take a look at the
data that demonstrate why right here
anyways he you know it's kind of tough
to look there's also a different version
that's only english- speaking where you
don't hear uh the two different
languages by the way he goes flat out
calling out
everybody for 23 minutes straight damn
to their faces I love that he calls out
the if you're ever invited to the world
economic Forum to give a speech and
people later on are going to say say
well look at him he went and spoke out
the world economic Forum yeah but he
went and called out everybody to their
faces this is the way to do it the way
he just did it yeah I love this and this
is something that I've been looking way
into these days what he's basically
talking about is something that we're
going to be prepared or have to be
prepared to face in the next coming
Generations okay and that is what is
called a clash of civilizations and a
clash of civilizations is not about
countries it's about ideas and it's
about cultures and what we're seeing is
an East versus West culture Clash so on
one hand you have democracy you have
capitalism you have freedoms you have
free markets you have human rights you
have Builders you have creators you have
discussions open expression and on the
other hand you have what he called
collectivism you have the marxists you
have the Communists you have the
authoritarian you have the jihadists you
have the extremists you have people that
want to tear down and Destroy and what
he's doing is saying listen World
economic for listen world there's a
flash of civilizations coming pick your
team and here in America we know what
team we're on I Tom did you hear the
speech or no no i' I've I've read the
summary of
it and and I S saw this live here but I
have not read the thing all the way but
I know the code words he's speaking with
and when he says collectivism he's
talking about communism because he
specifically says socialism now he says
collectivism collectivism is communism
communism with a gun is Marxism so what
he saying is look if two people have you
know
um Vinnie and I are sitting here and I
have an orange and you tell me chop half
and give it to him we both have half an
orange but that's all we can have
there's no way to grow more oranges
you've just taken half of mine because
you're not supporting capitalism or
growth and collectivism res results in
everybody impoverished Because unless
you're at the size of the United States
with the monetary power that we have
your currency goes down in value so so
guess what you impoverish your entire
nation by trying to give everybody some
something destroying the incentive to
work you destroy the growth of your of
your country and the value of your
currency so it all goes down and we're
impoverished that's what he said in
those first five minutes you know what
else he says in a speech he says in the
speech that just because a business
fails doesn't mean capitalism doesn't
work right just because you fail as an
entrepreneur doesn't mean capitalism
doesn't work this concept about every
time a business fails or doesn't work oh
this whole thing doesn't work we have to
change the entire system no that's not
the case here four basic principles of
capalm that we have to keep talking
about freedom to buy freedom to sell
freedom to try freedom to fail you're
going to fail at times the message was
so beautiful and he used data he used
history he used examples it was the most
uncomfortable speech to Listen to If you
believe in socialism and communism my my
my question is like they knew that he
was going to do this I mean you know you
know where he stands if you watched any
videos of this guy you know exactly
where he stands why would they invite
this guy to come there and CLA SCH bring
him on stage if it's going going against
their narrative I don't know why great
question but I actually want to applaud
them for giving a diverse opinion of
voices 1,00% when you just thought Claus
Schwab couldn't get more evil like the
fact that they let this guy go up there
and speak I think that's that's
fantastic because they knew what they
were going to get I have an idea for you
Tom look at look at the other way they
couldn't not invite
him how do you not Tom here's something
that I think that you should do over the
next coming months or years this guy's
going to be the perfect case example if
he can turn Argentina around first
libertarian that's ever been elected
certainly in Argentina possibly in the
world libertarian he's the first
Libertarian president ever okay that's
what I'm saying that's what I'm saying
so we see what's going on down in
Argentina they currency deflated
unemployment Skyrocket everything it's a
mess it's an absolute mess back in the
day how don't whatever many years ago
Argentina buiders used to be the Paris
of of Latin America what are they now
they're a laughing stock but it took
this guy to come in and say AA it's not
gonna happen on my watch so let's see if
he can actually turn this country around
because if he does he deserves all the
praise in the world yeah I'm excited
about seeing what's going to happen here
but more importantly calling out BS more
and more people call on out BS is a
beautiful thing that's taking place to
the world Vinnie so NAC natural asset
companies this is something that they
were talking about at World economic
Forum what can you tell us about NAC so
uh I got a message from uh a guy this
sick and dope uh man is he was like
Vinnie you guys need to talk about this
nobody is talking about it I you know I
want to have this Farmland he messages
you on man he messages me on man and
today apparent I think today is the the
last day that you can actually go out
there on the public record and try to
fight uh fight this thing so I'm going
to go really fast uh uh his name is
Reginal let me find this guy really
really quick give me two seconds uh
Reggie okay here he goes so he he
messages me and says Vinnie I'm sending
you this man uh in regarding something
about called natural asset companies we
have a chance to leave a public comment
opposing a m Monet uh monetizing of
Natural Resources it ends tomorrow which
is today so this this thing allows
everything from the land the air animals
plants minerals to be traded on the N uh
New York City stock exchange and
monetized creating something called
assets class of billionaire oligarchs
and he's he's concerned because you know
his kids you know he wants his kids to
be able to hunt and do the stuff on the
land so um it's connected it's connected
to the world economic Forum it's a
desire to to create this class uh
gobbling up our public lands and
waterways and opportunity for public
comment and today's the last day and I I
I'll send Rob the link uh but there's a
new uh phrase called EOS side I don't
know if you've heard this s side Eco
side which is actually elal side which
is allowing unelected Elites to tell
Farmers to stop farming I mean this is
their goal we know what they're doing we
know what China's buying up all this
land Bill Gates is one of these what one
let's let's stay on that so let's let's
fine EOS side so Eco side it's it's it's
letting uh they want Farmers to stop
farming Fishers to stop fishing Miners
to stop Mining and when you allow those
things to happen this is what you starve
and unrest starts to happen the so uh
Society starts to collapse I have a
video I sent Rob uh Greta thunberg and
her friend uh the CEO of stop ecosite
International her name is JoJo meta
demanded during the world economic Forum
on Tuesday uh that they dubbed where
nature meets conflict on Tuesday it's a
new international criminal category of
ecocide to prevent the mass damage so
they don't want you fishing they don't
want you doing anything and they want
people to be able to trade and invest on
your land even if you own it and this is
what her at this is just her attitude on
fishing and stuff uh this is at World
economic this world economic for okay go
ahead I mean EOS side as a word is
becoming more it's becoming better known
around the world and the concept is
generally Mass damage and destruction of
nature um but legally speaking um what
our organization and other the
collaborators aimed to do is to have
this recognized legally as a serious
crime because one of the issues that
sort of pervades all of this discussion
is that is that we have a kind of
cultural very grained habit of not
taking damage to Nature as seriously as
we take damage to people and property um
and that I mean you know if you're
campaigning for human rights at least
you know mass murder torture all of
these things are serious crimes but
there's no equivalent in the
environmental space um and so and and
you know unlike a an International crime
like genocide that in involves a
specific intent with ecocide what we see
is actually what people are trying to do
what businesses are trying to do is make
money is you know is Farm is fish is do
all of these things that are um you know
producing energy and so on um as well
but what's what's missing is the
awareness and the conscience around the
side effects around the collateral
damage that happens with that yeah
fishing fishing and stuff on your own
land they want to and so Robert Robert
sent me this so basically they can rule
private property laws under the guys are
protecting the environment they can
basically control and the dude they're
going to be trading air do you
understand like air water what are your
thoughts on this uh I think this needs
to shake out a little bit there's a
little bit of inflammatory speech going
on both sides but what you basically
have is the greens are trying to find
more ways to impose their will and if
the EPA won't do it fast enough if the
Paris Accords won't do it fast enough
they're trying to find other ways to do
it and what you heard her say is she was
equating and basically what she's
talking about is strip mining where you
go for coal and you dig those big pits
with all the levels on them that you can
see which are pretty devastating right
because a lot of that run offence up in
streams which is bad so there's
something that's bad she's trying to
equate that with genocide and to put put
a criminal penalty on it that's her
that's one of that's one of those angles
and so they're trying to find new ways
to invoke an environmentalist and uh
green agenda is what they're trying to
do and we should learn about this
understand it has a little bit of
traction but also has a hell of a lot of
resistance right now and the resistance
is correct and I sent Rob I sent Rob the
link for people to get on the SEC do.
gov to to file your your your your
grievance and say no they need comments
to make this not happen because this is
horrible if this goes through it's not
going to be good uh Adam yeah I don't
this is the first time hearing this I
respect to you with this here's what I
will know and I'll give a shout out to
our friend Constantine kiss from
trigonometry I remember when he got up
on there in Oxford and lectured the
global uh disaster the climate crisis
crowd who basically think the world is
coming to an end he said listen you have
to understand here in the UK we have the
luxury of having such a great life that
we can worry about all the problems that
don't actually exist right now but
everything that's going on in the
climate is going to be solved if it ever
is in the poor countries in the in the
highly populated core poor countries
like China India Latin America Brazil
because they're putting out the biggest
forms of uh pollution in the world but
you think that a poor Indian is waking
up living in the slums of Mumbai and
being like huh that global warming thing
dude they're trying to survive yep okay
so the poor people
are the people that are going to suffer
the most by by this type of agenda so
they're looking on how to pay the rent
and basically put some food on the table
and you're living in your high-rise in
New York or London worried about the
existential crisis that doesn't really
exist so it's all about perspective
people like to put all these pictures
out there of all the negative that's
happened I saw a very short documentary
on Chernobyl and so Chernobyl a terrible
econ economic disaster for the city and
for the people and a human disaster and
then just an environmental disaster but
you know what they look back 20 years
after Chernobyl you know what happened
there they took satellite pictures and
looked the vegetation and things that
had grown back over it was amazing so it
shows that Earth and trees and shrubs
and everything that was there with
whatever rainfall it gets it grew back
and it was this massive like like little
microforest that had grown in after
after in other words after man left all
this stuff grew and they still had this
horrible thing in the middle it's
radioactive yes true but you also know
that the Earth heals itself pretty quick
everything grew back and they said all
this vegetation here is creating a whole
lot of oxygen and we still have this ice
sorts in the middle but so all of this
thing they only want to show one side
you know we stripped mine and we did all
this they don't want to show replanting
all the trees they don't want to show
that if you leave it alone for 20 years
that all of a sudden you get the
equivalent of force that grows back what
what was this documentary called it was
it was about Chernobyl it was short it
was about 10 minutes long
think some of these are the pictures
that you see of Chernobyl where you see
incred growth now that doesn't change
the fact in the middle of it is this
little radioactive pit but it does show
you how that if we don't keep cutting
the trees down the trees grow back if we
don't cut the brush down the brush grows
back the the the Earth best thing you
said is the earth finds a way to heal
itself that's why it's called Mother
Nature because women grow life oh my
gosh we all have mothers here guys you
can find profile on Tinder he's in swipe
right he's okay all right let's let's
keep going all right so Rob can you
before we get into the story with Nikki
Haley can you pull up the CJ stoud uh
postgame Victory Speed so here it is and
by the way the complex sports is showing
this on Instagram and when you go right
go go on the uh they're going to show
you both of them go one more Rob uh uh
that's the one okay so if you can pause
right there you're going to hear the
edited version of his postgame speech by
ABC and then you're going to hear exact
ly what he says the original version go
ahead Rob season and a record setting
performance for you what does this
moment mean I mean it's been amazing
being in this city for as short as I've
been but first foremost I just want to
give all glory and praise to my Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ I mean it's been
amazing me your first NFL season they
took out they literally edited what are
you worried about ABC yeah what what
what NBC has come under Fire I'm sorry
it's NBC correction what are you worried
about NBC W and by the way who told you
to edit that is this an editor that
edited because you didn't know anything
about it so they did it or did somebody
have to prove the fact that you have to
cut that out or did the boss at the top
say cut that out or did somebody that
you're getting money from saying there's
no way in the world we're going to let
the clips about you who I just want to
know who said cut that that's all I care
about who because what if he says I want
to thank Allah yeah I don't care
Muhammad I want to thank Muhammad go for
it you think they're going to cut that
no no but that's not the point though I
want to thank whoever you want to thank
go for it you want to cut this out isn't
that is it is it is and by the waybo
used to say that all the time and they
didn't edit it very weird and isn't it a
weird because we we don't know we'll
never know but I'm telling you right now
and I've been feeling this a lot and
I've getting crazy amount of messages on
theck about stuff like this it's like
they're slowly they them the top All NBC
from Sony from all these all these
artists all these people they're taking
away God out of everything P because
they want cuz if there's no God you can
do whatever you want you could feel free
if you've been if you guys have been
paying attention to any of these artists
the the Taylor Swifts the Billy ish the
little Nas X just made another video
called J Christ where he is mocking
Jesus Christ the entire video okay he's
on a cross he's he's walking flamboyant
showing off his nakedness he has a a
thing on his neck that says sex but he
has the the the rosaries in his hand and
he comes out and makes an apology he's
like listen this isn't an apology he
literally says this is an apology I'm
just it's just art it's just art no no
they're mocking God they're taking away
God for somebody to edit out the guy
that's giving out Jesus Christ they
don't want clown he's a clown but guess
what he has sold his soul just like the
rest of them I think it's disgusting I
appreciate that but back to NBC there
are forces and editors and producers at
NBC I'm unsurprised by this why am I
unsurprised because you saw Rachel
mattow you know dissing dissing you know
white Christians saying the problem in
Iowa is all these white Christians with
their agenda look at the talking points
that were allowed to Prevail in MSNBC
and this is NBC Sports inside NBC there
is an anti-christian point of view and
they are editing it it makes it
unsurprising to me when I see it I'm
annoyed but it's unsurprising for me to
see it because you can see it coming out
in many other programming angles so
that's your question Tom because it's
NBC it's sewn it's all the artists it's
all the stuff that people consume my
question is why why why the push on such
an anti- relig just just the guy's
thinking Jesus Christ you know I don't
know if you guys know who Jesus Christ
was the cool guy that came here and said
hey everybody love each other and they
murdered him what why why such a push of
of talking about this positive person
people are going to say things this is
going to pop up in in the comments I'm
going to say it listen you know you
believe there's a Creator you believe
there's a lord you believe there's a
savior there is an equal there's not an
equal but there is an opposite Force out
there and there the forces of evil and
and it's real it's real you look at the
eyes of a lot of people and you can see
people say look at that guy he just
looks evil creeps me out that's real
you're having a spiritual response to
reality what's there and so it does not
surprise me that people without an
anchor will let their personal boat
drift and then be saying things calling
it art and acting in this way and
editing out things that they they think
they don't agree with and so look man
you know you're you're messing with the
guy that invented lightning you know by
the way let me let me tell you what I
saw the the other day to to counter all
this mess Michael Porter you know who
Michael Porter Jr is basketball player
good player yeah Denver Nuggets yeah
then we he's got hops he's good he's
very exciting to watch he's doing a
podcast with this girl if you can type
in Michael Porter human traffic in and
just go to images I just looked at the
YouTube the only thing they have is like
the 48 minute version I don't have 48
minutes to go through it but I watched a
short clip of it the other day that's
the one right there zoom into that one
right there that image so he's sitting
there with this girl okay attractive
girl she's exp she's talking to him
about human trafficking and what
happened okay at the end of the
interview you know what he says he says
would it be okay with you if I invited
you to church she says the last time I
went to church I was 12 years old he
says I told son would you go to church
with me he says yes and he says would it
be okay with you if I prayed for you wow
he says yeah I guess he gives the best
prayer man it was so awesome I now I
want see I wish you if Rob if you can
find it I would love to show the prayer
he prays over her he prays over her you
know that you know this isn't her fault
God please come give her this to to
understand she didn't do anything wrong
it's not her fault when she was human
trafficked and he invites you to go to
church wow how awesome is that you know
for so there's stories like this when
you're saying you know they want to take
uh Jesus out or they want to take God
out they're not going to win
because the NBA is filled is this the
one uh uh yeah this is the one watch
this can you just I'm so glad you watch
this if you can get the audio yeah there
you go go Ahad and play the clip it's
just one minute long look what he
says if I could pray for you and then I
wanted to invite you to church on Sunday
because you said you haven't been to
church for a while I haven't been to
church since I was like 12 12 years old
so let's go
Sunday um so yeah I just want to end
this podcast for you yeah that's totally
fine all right dear Lord thank you for
cat I want to thank you um just the
woman she is Lord and I just want to
thank you for the healing that you've
brought about in her life and giving her
the the vulnerability and the courage to
share her story um just thank you for
for the woman she is I ask that you make
yourself real to her um heal her in ways
that she didn't even know was
possible um show yourself to her make
her whole um give her complete
confidence and wholeness in herself and
just help her realize that the things
that happen to her are not her fault
um there's no shame there's no guilt
there you you take that all on yourself
and just please show her that uh we love
you and we appreciate you and we thank
you that even though terrible things
happened to to all of us that you
somehow can turn that into a beautiful
story in Jesus name amen wow good for
you Michael Porter Jun wow does that not
give you to choose to I was holding back
tears more than CH wow more than CH fre
by the way the the sport is filled all
the sports are filled with guys like
this man what a moment what a moment
right it also shows you the power of
light over Darkness the light has
infinite power over Darkness you just
have to be able to see it and people and
people of power don't want you to see
stuff like that and that's why they edit
out videos because tell me what a what a
great gesture what a great thing you
felt it she felt it and that dude that
changes that changes that moment your
your day your life like that that's such
a powerful thing for them shout out to
CJ strout and Michael Porter Jr you guys
keep at it we see you let me give you a
little perspective CJ Stout okay praying
Jesus what day of the week do you think
that was on that game Sunday it was on
Sunday right
yeah make no mistake about it the NFL is
competing with Jesus good point there's
many people out there who pick sitting
at home watching football whether they
went out on Saturday night or not that
they are not waking up and going to
church there's been a shift in this
country we talked about this in the lack
of values that are declining in America
today whether it's religion whether it's
culture whether it's Community uh
whether it's community service whatever
the things are the morals morals are
declining in this country the only moral
that has basically stayed the same is
what money so the NFL is competing
directly or indirectly with God there's
been a clash of civilizations as we
talked about and it's it's money over
God great point so you have someone over
like CJ shout saying listen bro I just
want to thank my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ that should never be edited
whatsoever in America We Believe on
freedom of speech we're founded on judeo
Christian values it is what it is but as
people stop going to church stop going
to Temple stop praying stop going to
mosque whatever it is they're going to
fall into some sort of ideology and
that's what we've seen the young people
The Tick Tock gen the Gen Z generation
praying to president she of China Tik
Tok to
basically fulfill their ideology whether
it's wokeism whether it's IDE LBG lgbtq
plus whatever can't even see how many
Stu they got going on and I'll give you
one quick Story I played college
football I played in North Carolina and
then I transferred to Florida State I
was the only Jew on the team there were
100 people on the team at the end of
every practice we all huddled up and the
coach all right all right guys hle up
now coach Kirby right here all right
everybody bow your head and he would
give a prayer guys you know uh protect
us Lord blah blah blah blah blah
everything yeah in Jesus name we pray
and I'm sitting there like okay it's all
good cool as a Jew I don't have to I'm
just closing my eyes praying for the
team we're so easily offended in this
country if I didn't ever go to the ad
and say I'm Jewish I can't dude I shut
the [__] up and I pray yeah so for for
the country to not for was it NBC NBC to
edit this out and I'm sure they'll give
well it was a oneoff time one editor you
know I'm sure whatever but there's
clearly something going on this country
pushing God and religion and what's
right out of our lives and whatever else
that's bad into our lives they're
certainly not going to take little Nas
X's devil dancing video off the table
nope promot it so again shout out to CJ
and to Porter good for you guys uh let's
go to the next story here all right next
story uh Red Sea risk to oil very real
prices could change rapidly if Supply
disrupted Chevron CEO says let me read
this and then time I'm coming to
you so here we go the crisis in the Red
Sea posed a serious risk to oil floats
and prices could change quickly if
tensions lead to a major Supply
disruption in the Middle East Chevron Co
Michael worth told CNBC on Tuesday it's
a very serious situation and seems to be
getting worse worth said in an interview
to at the world economic for and Davos
the Chevron said he was surprised that
the US crude oil was trading below $73 a
barrel because the risk was very real so
much of the world's oil flows through
the region that were uh uh that were to
be cut off I think you could see things
change very rapidly and he continues
that we really have to watch this very
very carefully Tom what does this really
mean to the average person okay the CEO
of Chevron is saying that if the supply
goes down and we're all still demanding
you know we still have demand for
consumers and countries to you know to
have oil for energy and all the things
that that it creates Aviation gas diesel
fuel you know gasoline for your car the
whole thing what he's saying is that if
Supply is disrupted prices are going to
go up but there's something most
Americans don't know and robas pull a
couple charts are really really quick
first of all you have the US fax chart I
sent you a link us fax uh um and then go
down the to the little chart down there
no no no
usax I said there was three links in the
email one of them is just called from
usax and uh there we go go down the
bottom the United States became energy
independent in 2020 in other words we
produced more crude oil than we used in
2020 and there's been no turning back no
turning back whatsoever and so what he's
talking about is the supply and demand
he's saying I'm surprised us rude is
below 73 a barrel because if the supply
goes down because of you know the Red
Sea and the houthis and you can't get
shipping around he would expect the
price would go up because there's less
oil going around it's more valuable and
so that's the point he's making and here
in the United States the uh oil
companies pre price gasoline so if they
think that the World Market is going up
for the oil they charge us that price
for barrel of oil they don't charge us
like a home team discount for the oil so
people think that oh gas goes up in the
United States cuz we can't get oil from
the Middle East it'll be terrible won't
be able to drive Drive our car that's
wrong last year the the total oil wells
in America that were pumping they shut
off 35% of them because they were trying
to move the price back up to the above
55 because they needed to be above 55 to
make it economical for oil here but
check that out there it is and then two
other real quick is you you you'll love
this so we produce more than we use so
we're we've been a net exporter and on
the Spock Market our actually biggest
trading partner is Canada and so people
don't seem to understand what they're
talking about so and you get back to it
and when they pre-ra prices that's when
States like California had hearings on
this you're gouging you think the price
of oil is going to go up so you raise it
and they go yeah sure we did right you
know Exxon made uh go back 2022 Exxon
was 56 billion in profit Chevron was 35
billion in profit and we ready to burn
them at the stake and execute them
because they pre-priced where the oil
was going to go well meanwhile Amazon
made 225 billion in profit and we didn't
talk about that about driving small you
know community stores retailers out of
business we didn't seem worried about
that but we tend to run to this it's a
simple supply and demand thing the price
of oil goes up the price of oil goes
down and guess what it affects us here
too so what Americans should worry about
on an international stage
is when oil is disrupted in the Middle
East guess what US companies can sell
the oil we pump at a higher price to
other people out there then we would
sell it to ourselves and that's why our
gas goes up but if World War III breaks
out we have got plenty of oil here in
the United States drill baby drill so
from a macro socioeconomic standpoint
let me tell you why this is important
now because listen when's the first time
you were heard the word hthy Rebels how
long ago I mean a couple years ago not
too long ago okay most people 90% of
people haven't nobody's heard of these
people yeah okay like they they think
it's houthi and the Blowfish if you
think about it sometimes or they heard
the word Somali pirate now they know who
it is exctly well I mean that Somalia is
a totally different country than Yemen
the houthis are in Yemen but here's the
point yeah the houthis aim to govern
Yemen and support external forces
against the United States Israel and
Saudi Arabia so what's my point is there
there's been a civil war in Yemen pay
attention to the jihadists over here pay
attention to the Gaza Brigade there's
been a Civil War in Yemen since 2014
nobody talks about this they don't Saudi
Arabia and Iran are having a proxy war
for the last
decade millions of people in this
country of Yemen have died you don't
hear about this where's the Gaza Brigade
here talking about the innocent Arabs
that are dying and they should and it's
horrible but the reality is once they
start when Israel gets involved and all
of a sudden these um
these Regional conflicts pop up and Iran
starts basically funding the houthis and
Hamas and Hezbollah terrorist organiz
organizations Iran is basically the
greatest destabilizing force in the
Middle East possibly in the world other
than China all of a sudden America's
going to take notice because you know
what America don't play with and you
know what the EU don't play with you
know what the UK don't play their money
this right here what country did we
learn or what what the Horn of Africa
the one city that China has a base jibou
jaib boti and it's fun to say you know I
like I want to get to you booty but the
reality is this this Red Sea this
shipping area is one of the most busy
ports uh seas in the world and the houie
rebels are messing with people's money
big time and when you start messing with
people's money you start messing with
trade routes all of a sudden we don't
play that game right there so that what
they're doing the houthis to bring up
Tom's point they make the Somali pirates
of I am the captain now Tom Hanks they
make them look like the JV Squad to Echo
what
Obama said Obama Osama Obama B Obama
about Isis right there but these houie
Rebels again funded by Iran funding by
the mafia likee regime that's going on
in Iran are looking to sew chaos and in
the world of 2024 we know that the the
word this year is chaos US represents
order and a world of chaos in the Red
Sea meanwhile Bernie Sanders says to
force vote to freeze a to Israel and US
puts houes back on the terrorist list
this is a story from Wall Street Journal
the Biden Administration plans to put
houti Rebel group on one of its list of
terrorist organization days after the US
launch strikes on its facilities in
Yemen in retaliation for months of
attacks on Commercial vessels in the Red
Sea about time we're doing this the
designation bars people or companies in
the US from offering just about any kind
of support to the group and prohibits
its members from entering the US it also
requires us financial institutions to
freeze any funds they hold belonging to
the group or under its control and us
obviously recently carried out
additional strikes against htis in Yemen
while this is taking place Adam thoughts
on this story yeah well it just proves
uh more and more and more that Bernie
Sanders is a loser everybody knows it so
it's becoming clear and clear that the
guy has never built anything in his life
and we talked about Bernie Sanders here
all the socialists want to do the
Democratic socialists is tear down
they've never built anything what has
Bernie Sanders ever do he's a career
professional loser politician he's done
nothing and he's basically spoiled milk
at this point so he's out there whatever
his stance are I think we've realized
there's no math there's no numbers
behind any of his opinions you know he
used to basically uh Stomp and raid and
talk trash about millionaires then he
became a millionaire then it then it
moved to billionaires right how many
times did he say millionaire millionaire
the Millionaires and the millionaires
now it's the Millionaires and the
billionair
no it's the billionaires you're talking
about somebody so and this whole concept
of
intersectionality right of anyone who's
oppress has to identify with people who
oppress around the world Constantine
kiss the second time I've mentioned his
name he's trigonometry he went in UK and
he went to the people who are Marching
for Gaza okay and and what's going on
there is horrible and nobody wants to
see innocent civilian lives period
whether it's on the Israeli side whether
it's on the gazin side whether it's
what's going on in Iran and uh Pakistan
these days if you see that that's little
whether it's going on in Yemen nobody
wants to see innocent civilians but in
war unfortunately this is sort of the
damage the collateral damage that
happens right there and he started
interviewing all these people that are
holding signs and he goes what's what's
this sign right here oh it's a we're
calling for the Socialist intifa and he
starts asking these people white people
in London who are Marching and and he's
like what is a socialist intifa they're
like honestly dude I got no clue what's
going on here I got no clue mate they
just gave me a sign I'm out here I don't
want to see dead people
and what we realize is kind of like how
Jamie D was saying ask questions like
why why why what's going on here what he
did and shout out to you constanton I
sent you a text he went he's like well
why do you what's going on here what
does it mean from the river to the Sea
what does this mean what does that mean
they're like oh mate I got no idea like
I got no clue what's going on so are
they holding the sun exactly so they're
just there's just they what do they call
just like usel useful idiots out there
marching in the real world and you have
someone a useful idiot real life useful
idiot Like Bernie Sanders um who makes
some noise he's inspired the squad and
the aoc's and the ilhan Omars and the
Presley of the world and Rashida Talib
and that's their weird cult leader but
this is someone who has built nothing in
his life and only wants to tear
something and never ever ever trust
anybody that Combs his hair with a
balloon have you seen his hair Tom
Bernie stand listen I want to talk I
take a balloon I ha he's he's he's a
professional loser period end story you
know it's funny when you look at things
now it's lip doesn't move when he talks
it's funny he should have been the one
running against Trump two populists with
different messages obviously Hillary you
know did what she needed to do but it's
become increasingly clear and clear
especially since being a part of value
tainment capitalism is the way
capitalism is how you basically lift
people out of poverty and this guy's
pedaling socialism Democratic socialism
but at the end of the day it's all
nonsense and like Tom's and about
splitting the orange you only have one
orange and if you chop it up in half
you're going to get some you're not
going to get some you got to create more
was going somewhere else when he brought
up the orange I thought he was talking
about like you know additional source of
income for for Vinnie and I I thought
vitamin C I don't know what you
offensive but I didn't know what he was
I really want to get your opinion on
this because you actually I know you're
no fan of Bernie Sanders but you've
given him credit because he is a True
Believer oh listen I you know why uh AOC
you know Perfect story with AOC
AOC is unbelievable at what she does
driver salesperson of if if you have AOC
on your side whatever the ideas she
supports she's going to be the loudest
person selling those ideas you don't
have to agree with the ideas you wish
you had an aocc on your side AOC is the
kind of person you want same with Bernie
you know again don't agree with the
ideas don't agree with his approach
don't agree with 90% of the stuff that
he talk every once in a while he does
say some stuff where you're like okay
this kind of does make sense but you
know what the guy's been he's such a
True Believer and a believer of you know
communism or socialism the guy went on
his honeymoon to freaking Russia crazy
and not not during the current Russia
we're talking like
USSR reolution realize like where do you
want to can you imagine like somebody
right now says where do you want to go
for uh your honeymoon guy says dude for
sure we're going to we're going to Gaza
because uh that's where we're going for
honeymo we're going to go to Iran for a
honeymo we're going to go hang out in
Syria with Bashar Al Assad that's where
enjoy all the laps of luxuries that
going say they're True Believer so this
guy's a True Believer I just don't uh
think he's got way too many
contradictions in his arguments okay Tom
California they just come out out of top
50 states that have lost the most people
in 2023 the ones that gained the most
number one is Florida number two is
Texas number three is Tennessee the ones
who have lost the most at the 50th spot
is California 49 is New York and I want
to say 48 is Illinois what data do you
have with how bad and ugly things are
with money in regards to California oh
this this is wonderful this is where you
know that it all comes home to roost so
we hear about oh you know the the number
one salesman of the year for U-Haul is
Gavin Nome you know our star salesman we
hear about the people moving back and
forth and all that that let's talk about
AGI what's AGI adjusted gross income so
in other words the total income that the
State loses and the total income that
the state gains yeah California lost in
36 months 23 22 21 $29 billion doll of
AGI left the state that a b with a B
with a B Cal Florida Vanessa with a B
Florida received 30 $9
billion of AGI coming in by the way the
rest of the top 10 recipients receive 38
billion so Florida at number one had
more AGI come in than the next nine wow
damn that were on the plus list which
includes Texas and Tennessee just like
talk about now the next thing I went and
and did say so so if California lost $38
billion what' they lose so let's say 0.1
nobody pays taxes to California and the
average tax to Californians average
remember their tax is 13.3% but the
average paid is about 75% so you take 7
half% of this and suddenly you get $2.1
billion in income tax that Sacramento
did not receive because the people left
the second thing is you take about um
30% of that you send it to the federal
government because they have to pay tax
to the federal government and you're
left with a net savings rate in of like
5% so in other words the remaining
leaves you $2 billion that they didn't
pay sales tax on so 20 billion time 7%
in California is another 1.4 billion so
the states and cities missed $4
billion and then the rest of the state
that 20 billion didn't buy
anything haircuts at super cut bought a
car from the car dealership it bought
nothing it didn't buy energy it didn't
buy anything so California's net loss of
of all of that was $20 billion in
Commerce that people didn't spend and up
to $5 billion that never made it to
Sacramento or the communities Florida
that 39 billion when you do the same
math it
was 5 billion that was received by the
governments of Florida because there's
no income tax just in sales tax and
minor tax it's also on gas and then it
brought do the same math you send uh 25%
to the federal government it leaves
almost $30 billion do in New Commerce
buying and selling stuff to the people
here so when you hear about the
population going back and forth there's
where it comes home to RSE Gavin Nome
where are you going to find the $5
billion in tax receipts for you and the
local counties that collect the uh sales
tax where are you gonna find it dude
where are you gonna find it Tom let me
ask you a question so do you remember
yeah do you remember back in the days
Governor Perry would come to Texas and
say hey if you're a small business owner
and they're not taking care of you here
and you're paying all this money and
taxes come to Texas come to California
you come to Texas no no he was saying
come toex he went to California to give
went to California going on all the
radio shows recruiting small businesses
to go to Texas so you and I were at an
in conference in Arizona and there we
met a mayor mayor maso right who was
from Frisco and it was a two or three-
term mayor of Frisco he took a city of
5,000 people uh can you type in Frisco
population type in Frisco population
today it's got to be 10 oh it was
149,000 when we lived there holy [__]
it's at 21,000 in 2021 grow since it's
insane they went from 5,000 to 200,000
in less than 30 years look they did they
did it the right way they bought schools
infrastructure Vinnie there was nothing
in Frisco and you lived right there in
Plano I want to say but we were in fris
every weekend every weekend we were at
fris to go to that mall and look at if
Frisco's about to pass up Plano you see
how plano's Flatline Frisco is not
Flatline it's gonna keep growing serious
so we go there and Governor Perry is
recruiting businesses away from
California and you know what Perry did
Perry got us thinking Perry got a lot of
people in Texas thinking why am I paying
for this so one day I get a knock on a
door you remember this Woodland Hills
office guy knocks on the door and he
says yeah um we're here to see Patrick B
David uh what for yeah we're here to see
you yeah this is a we're here to collect
County tax county tax yes what do you
mean County tax yeah you owe County tax
how do you know what I owe County tax I
pay my state of my federal yeah but
there are some counties in La you got to
pay and the county you're you how much
do I have to pay you they give me some
number I don't know what the number was
like $80,000 $70,000 I'm like what yeah
so I call my accountant I said hey what
is this all about they said well it's
hit and miss if you're public and they
not publicly traded but if your
company's growing and the public knows
about it they come knocking on your
doing collect the money and if they find
you you have to pay for it I said you
got is this is such said no you got to
pay for it so we pay for
it then I learned California has 11 or
13 counties you can go to where there is
no County tax Victorville Valencia
whatever I don't I'm not saying
Valencia's account but there's 13 cities
municipalities that you don't pay any
taxes in County taxes in glendel Burbank
was one of them okay that you don't pay
that you don't pay taxes in and I
obviously I was not going to go to
Victorville I don't know if you've been
to Victorville I have been Victor is a
very kind of situation very did they got
yoshimoto there no not yoshimoto I
corrected you on Instagram Yoshi Noya
not Yos Yos whatever it's still 7-Eleven
hot did you see the Ral under right
there you hear the
under Victorville looks like Las Vegas
before there was Las Vegas are that's
exactly the way to put it yes so 70
years ago anyways moral the story is
what moral the story is we left Woodland
Hills and we went to Glendo to avoid
County taxes why am I my paying for this
then they wouldn't continue with taxes
regulation all this stuff and then
eventually we moved when Governor Perry
started coming and recruiting we went to
Texas for a meeting and it was mayor
maso and his Camp they picked us up at
the airport we went and had a good time
with them then they took us to meet with
Nolan Ryan uh uh Donnie Nelson the son
who you know live in a community in
Frisco that we were looking at beautiful
area I love and then when I met with
Governor Perry and there were a bunch of
CEOs that they were recruiting to the V
why are you paying how do you feel about
paying the state taxes you're paying in
California you know you come here we
appreciate you here how do they look at
you when you go there don't they look at
you as those rich people that make in
Texas you're a hero to us we going to
take care of you yeah and then we get on
the car in the car we get back back on a
flight everybody's debriefing like man
these guys actually appreciate us
Southern Hospitality respect this this
that what happens California gradually
there was a Time Magazine artic article
came out Rob can you pull this up it was
called the United States of Texas type
in Time Magazine right next United
States of Texas then type in Time
Magazine yeah and go to images this is
like nine years ago 10 years ago I made
there you go what what year was it can
you zoom in a little bit so we can get
the date what year was this magazine
when it came out go to the top they 28th
of 2013 this is when I started selling
Texas to my guys moral will remember
this oh wow this is when I would pull
this out and say guys Texas Texas Texas
2 and a half years later I sold Melva
moral Jen didn't want to go to Texas
nobody wanted to go to Texas this
article is the reason what him this
article in Governor Perry is why we
ended up in Texas okay so here's the
point Tom what does Nome do to attract
small business owners to Texas when all
the data sucks Y and doesn't favor him
how do so be Newsome for a second
recruit me I'm a small business owner
out of Arizona sell me on coming to
California I'm in New Mexico I'm in
Arizona I'm in Nevada I'm in Texas sell
me on why I should move my business to
to California point one it's beautiful
the climate is beautiful the ocean is
beautiful the coast is beautiful it's
absolutely
gorgeous point
two I'll get back to
you that is it literally that what does
he have left put the comedy aside though
how do you sell it I don't know how you
sell it you don't have a labor base
they're they're
they're largely leaving it's hard for
your people now your people are going to
come here to almost two times the uh
housing cost and our insurance cost is
up but you know what they got the
climate and they got everything here it
is not possible article after article is
being written you can't sell the dream
all you can do if you're Gavin Nome is
is go snake oil on them it's overblown
you don't understand that there's lots
of great communities care about our
people they go to the emotion they go to
the liberal emotion we care about our
people we care about what's going going
on we're working on Healthcare things
we're working on insurance that we just
gave to all the illegal aliens at your
cost we're working on that they have to
go to the emotional argument about it's
overblown they're putting it in a bad
light come here check it out that's what
it is but there are no there is no
literal rational PowerPoint that be can
be crafted to get a business from
Arizona to to move to California we all
saw oh sorry we all saw the debate
between Dan santis and Nome anyone who
watched the first hour of the debate I
was like scratching my eyes out I'm like
Dan santis you have every piece of data
in your favor and this guy is somehow
spinning this and he's winning this
debate he's a trickster he's such a
dirty little trickster now if I was
governor Perry dude I would be able to
sell Texas to Californians in 10 seconds
uh talal in San Francisco move to Frisco
if you don't like taxes move to
taxes okay you don't like communism come
get some freedom in your life yeah taxes
versus Texas I see in Texas everything's
bigger in txas except for the taxes and
by the way so simple and Tom well Tom
it's it's simple and I know we kind of
thought he was joking but you know how
many people I talk to in California just
in general and I'm like what is going
like why the hell would you you made a
great Point Tom you know what a lot of
them say the the weathers like you can't
beat the weather the lifestyle people
are willing to sacrif M and taxes and
and crime and L literally crap in the
streets doo in the streets homeless
people everywhere but they go you know
what at least it's not like humid or
sticky and it doesn't rain that much
it's crazy that weather plays such an
important role in their decision stay
[__] perspective gives you everything
and when people from California take a
trip somewhere or they go to their
nephew's wedding in in Nashville and
they go wow it's kind of this is like
wow this is not a bad town this is not a
bad place how much you paying for the
house here we pay about this that's what
happens if you give a citizen true
perspective and some facts they flip
yeah and so the thing about California I
know people in California haven't been
out of California in 8 10 years you know
they they they're not trapped they're
not impoverished they just haven't gone
anywhere and really experienced it so
they are like the proverbial frog boiled
in the pot yeah the last time I went
back to California and I get back there
somewhat regularly and I've looked at
the San Fernando Valley you know what
I'm about to say and I drive up the same
streets that I used to drive up and I
can see the changes in the walls behind
houses and I can see the changes in the
road and the infrastructure and I go wow
this was happening while I was lived
lived here and I was the Frog being
boiled in the pot you give me
perspective somewhere else you give me
truth the funny thing is if for anybody
that's ever lived in California and
lived in Texas is should shouldn't even
be close California is so much better
than Texas on the surface of course good
call the oceans the mountains the
lifestyle the Palm Tre you kidding Mew
with the exception of Addison Texas and
the and the Yard House there that we
hung out all the time best speech and
award I don't want no part no Texas but
let me tell you something when you look
at your paycheck and if you're making
money all of a sudden there's an extra
133% to get down out of your baay check
n you
say sign me up buddy by the way check
this out let let me give you some stats
here you ready so we started our
headquarters the insurance company at a
northri California okay at the time 100%
of our agents were from Northridge
California okay so so this is this is
pretty wild um Rolo and cesi Vargas
first to leave first to leave California
they live H they went to Houston Texas
they're killing it by the way Jason went
to Dallas you got George went to Austin
you got got Jose went to Houston you got
literally Del Toro in they moved Del
Toro went to San Antonio do you realize
five Matt sapula went from Chicago to um
went from every single one of the board
councils move to the state of Texas all
all of them every one of them moveed to
the state of Texas yeah I'm telling you
what I just said to you right every one
of them moved to the state of Texas and
none of them are from Texas no they're
all from California or Chicago they
moved to Texas so this isn't like a you
know thing that's just happening that
small numbers here this has being
affected with a lot of different
businesses a lot of people different
moving by the way speaking of moving
quick stat you've talked about this why
Governor Nome was the U-Haul employee of
the year if you wanted to rent a U-Haul
because you talked about moving to move
from California to go to Texas it would
cost you how much
$3,000 but more but if you wanted to
move from Texas to California it was
basically free like that it was like
come on in yeah so the numbers just
don't add up all right so let's go to
the next door here so Strickland Sean
Strickland's being interviewed and this
guy asks him a question about transs and
you know comments was made and nobody
has a clue what the answer is going to
be and then Strickland just completely
turns it on him turns on him and flips
it on him and then
afterwards I know you got other things
to add to as well you you want to know
what what this was in reference that the
guy audience cuz Sean Strickland said I
think in 2022 or 21 he said if I had a
gay son uh I would think I failed as a
man to create such weakness he goes if I
had a a [__] for a daughter I'd think
she just wanted to be like her dad and
he l lol that that that was initial
comment so he's in Canada goe and watch
this here go for it uh we've got a
pretty supportive gay lesbian community
in this city I did want to ask you about
something you wrote A couple of years
ago you said if I had a gay son I would
think I oh another another I'm saying a
swamp you guys a swamp you become a
champion you become a star and and
someone let me ask you something are you
are you are you gay you have the chance
to back with a more diverse are you let
me know are you gay can I can I get an
answer well I'm asking this is part of
are you are you a gay man I'm an ally of
the community if you had a son then he
was like you know he had a son he was
gay you'd be like oh man you don't you
don't want a grandkid no problem with it
oh man well dudee you're a weak [__]
man dude you're like you're part of the
[__] problem you elected Justin Chau
like you [__] when he sees the bank
accounts like you're just [__]
pathetic and and the fact that the fact
that you have no [__] backbone and
and has he shut down your [__]
country and seiz bank accounts you ask
me some stupid [__] like that go [__]
yourself move the [__] on answer the
question but I did want to ask also
things you said about the trans
Community you said uh this past October
when they announced the budlight
sponsorship that you'd go so hard on
budlight in your next fight they'll have
to accept me or denounce me when uh when
they know what and will know what they
stand for are you this guy's like d this
Canadian is not that Canadian are you
still going to use your fight time to
kind of speak on that here's the thing
about
budlight here's the thing about
budlight 10 years ago to be trans was a
what a mental [__] illness and now
all of a sudden people like you have
[__] weasel your way in the
world you are you are an
infection you are the definition of
weakness everything that is wrong with
the world is because of [__] you and
the best thing is is the world's not
buying it the world's not buying your
[__] [__] you're [__] pedaling
the world is not saying you know what
you're right [__] chicks have dicks
the world's not saying that world's
saying no there are two genders I don't
want my kids being taught about you know
who they could [__] school I don't
their sexual preference like dude this
guy is a [__] enemy you want to look
at the [__] enemy to our world it's
that [__] right there that's
stupid [__] question by the way this
is two things wears his heart in his
sleeves and tells it as I mean obviously
not the smartest guy in the world but
you know what I respect out of this
whole thing too have you heard anything
from Dana or anybody the beauty about
the UFC is say what you want to say you
stand on your own two feet you say what
you want and the fact that he asked that
guy are you gay and the guy goes I'm an
ally Community what the hell does that
mean like I hook up with guys and then
like but I'm not gay just hook up with
my boyfriend not gay yeah I'm not gay
but my boyfriend that guy is gay the guy
that pounds me he's but what he's the
gay one what do you think about that
when you hear him say like stand up for
for what this guy is talking about and
how we've evolved what do you think this
is why UFC is so important I love the
UFC is getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and Dana doesn't care when they
say things like this and by the way
check this out even with the budlight
comment that he made he didn't call out
budlight because budlight is now a n fig
sponsor of the UFC and this guy's got
the audacity to say what he just said
right now no he's right though he is
right when he's calling out the BS of
him sitting there saying if your son was
gay would you be okay with that you let
be your grandfather I'm to I'm to I'm
totally I'm totally okay with that okay
I mean Mo the the reason why you have a
child is to continue the legacy of your
family and it out lives it and if your
son is gay you're not going to have a
biological child cuz he can't have a
biological child with another man they
have to go adopt and that's not your
biological child it's a great choice to
you know for those that choose to adopt
we to those families salute we need we
we need to applaud and respect a lot of
those family that do it the right way
right but he's calling out BS and I
actually respect it this by the way this
this answer could have never been given
in the NFL never in the NBA never in the
MLB never in the NHL nobody in those
Sports could have given an answer like
this except for the great UFC Ran by A
Man Named Dana White Tom your thoughts
when you hear something like this from
Sean Strickland I first of all I Echo
what you just said excuse me I'm sorry
the the other sports leagues are worried
about China worried about this worried
about that and they are at the whim of
their sponsors we heard Dana say very
clearly he leads the sport and he is not
at the win of this sponsors correct he
is absolutely not he appreciates them he
respects them they're making the economy
go around but they are not going to tell
him what to be or what to do whereas the
other leagues the tail wags the dog
that's the way it is the other leag you
think about what he said what Sean said
he is he is just projecting out
absolutely what his feelings are and he
there is a point of truth that he said
there he said 10 years ago we would have
regarded trans as a mental illness and
what he didn't say there and I'll add to
it is guidance counselor would have been
trying to get some counseling if a kid
so if a if a male comes in and makeup
and a dress 10 years ago to um a high
school and once you the girls room it
would have been whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa let's let's go down
sit down the guidance counsel's office
let's talk about this what's going on
here that would have been reaction now
it's like wait wait wait he's making his
choice hang on he's right he's right
about that 10 years ago be that and
we're all getting in the name of except
of whatever the acceptance of whatever
you know
a we are getting this and he's calling
it out and going back and he's dead
right on that point Adam this is the
problem with lumping in the L's the G's
the B's the t's the I's the a the it
they're all different type of people I
think what we're all trying to say is
listen if you're gay you're gay nobody's
got a problem like okay you're gay
you're lesbian to do it your thing are
you're by you're just a little confused
it's the
tease it's the tease where you want me
to pretend that that penis in between
your legs is actually a vagina okay
Dylan Mia all right we're playing this
game okay nothing to see here yeah and
then there's people just like yeah that
I don't I don't think so bro now we're
in America Freedom of Choice Freedom
religion freedom of perspective do what
you want nobody's got a problem with but
don't make that your I'm not I don't
walk around yo I [__] chicks bro it's
what I do I mean that's how you identify
I mean kind kind of do but that's not
how I identify that's not like call me a
great man everywhere I go it's like
that's not the identity that you're
looking for but if you look at the
numbers I know we're joking if you look
at the numbers Bill Mah pointed this out
Pat you can fact correct me
traditionalists okay less than 1%
identify as LGBT Baby Boomers 2% Gen X
5% Millennials 10% gen Z 19
20% listen in human history 20% of the
population is not gay you came on my
show as a trans you crush it was amazing
you said listen s trans is the new trend
yeah and it is that's the reality but
here's how here's how weird it gets when
he called out that guy he's like do you
want your son to be gay the guy's like I
have no problem with him do you want him
to be gay there's a part of that guy
that's like yeah I'm actually rooting
for that I think so I I actually want my
son to be gay not not okay if it happens
it happens you don't root for that
you're not pushing but that's what that
Ally is it's like Not only would I be uh
happy for it I'd be proud I'm rooting
for that so for example you're not let
me say this let me say this here I made
a comment to you yesterday and I'm going
to say this publicly so everyone knows
what my position is you said something
to uh Sarah hakabe Sanders right and I
gave feedback saying I don't like us
saying stuff about appearance women I'm
that's not my uh what do you call it uh
uh it's not your thing your it's not
because look everybody is got their own
insecurities and all this other stuff if
they attack us he let's roll I'm totally
okay with that let's have fun with that
but I don't want to go play that part
right it's just not part of who we are
not our brand not not it's just not not
what we represent you you always take
the feedback and it's good and we move
on but the the part the comment you made
right now where you said look the
problem isn't with the L the G or the b
or the the key or the T my problem is
not with any one of them my problem is
with
indoctrination and you imposing yourself
dude I don't give a [__] what you want
to do privately go do you okay I don't
care what you want to do how you want to
please yourself it's your choice go at
it don't advertise it don't get in my
face don't get in the face of my kids
don't get in the face of my schools that
my kids go to that is where we're going
to have a problem so it's got I don't
even have a problem with the tea people
the tea people have their places that
they go to and do the tea stuff guess
what go the te people is when a Forbes
chooses a Dylan mvan as a highlight of
one of their biggest conferences and you
put them as a hero type of person that's
my problem to me Forbes is a bigger
problem than Dylan malaney to me Tik
Tock media mainstream media that
highlights these stories is the bigger
problem because they're making them seem
like Heroes so another kid watches and
says hey can I be that I'm going to get
all this attention can I be that I'm
going to get all this attention it's the
hero making machine problem from the top
all the other stuff whatever you want to
do you do your thing everybody has their
own style of you know when you you you
if you date 20 different girls and if
you're woman listen to this if you're
dating different guys everybody has a
different way to be pleased no two are
the same somebody likes this somebody
likes that somebody likes this guess
what it's between that person and their
partner go do your thing no one's going
to be the same right go do your thing
privately the way you want to do that
keep it to yourself but I love the fact
that Sean Strickland has the audacity
and the brass to just call it out and by
the way he continues to say something to
his opponent what did he say he say to
his opponent this is how this is how
Wild Shan Strickland is so Sean
Strickland uh he has his own podcast
called the man dance he was also on Theo
Von's podcast which got me emotional
because he was so emotional talking
about the abuse that he went through
with his father and what his mother went
through and it was if you want if you
haven't cried in a while you want to cry
you watch it so he's he uh he warned uh
his the fighter that he's fighting this
this Saturday d
the uh not to cross the line ahead of
their bout in Toronto saying that if you
mention his childhood trauma uh he goes
it's going to transcend fighting he said
um he goes listen and I quote we're
going to try to murder each other but if
you bring up that [__] again I will
effing stab you he said he will stab him
and he goes if I go to Canada and you
bring it up well guess what I'm going to
jail they're going to deport me and we
spent 8 weeks for trading for noing
reason he goes listen say what you want
we're going to going to fight you bring
up what my father did one more time and
I'm going to St I believe that guy I
believe him I'm laughing because of the
key
and clip you did I swear to God you
living I'm going to eat your heart watch
this is the problem in the UFC is
where's the limits the great thing is
we're allowing No Limits but we had the
conversation with what Colby Covington
the other day what he said about uh the
other Fighters was it uh father what's
his name's Father Anthony I forget the
name whatever Edwards Edwards Edwards he
talked about um his dead father yeah
there's got to be some limits here to
this stuff there's either no limits or
limits well and in the UFC there's no
limits I mean listen it's it's words at
the end of the day yeah this line right
here Leon Edwards Leon Edwards yeah but
this guy used my dad's death as
entertainment by the way Colby had a
great time with you he literally choked
you out after the podcast literally
fantastic he did lose that fight yeah
but but but I mean in this sense like
this is childhood trauma and and and
again my attitude is it's no h bar this
guy talks trash you got to be able to
take it back but he's just letting him
know if you cross that line these are
the consequences and I believe that he
would do it he said I will effing stab
you in Canada and he goes all that eight
weeks of training goes out the window
cuz I'm going to go to jail the fight
card he goes I'm going to go to jail but
this weekend he's defending his title
against this is his first defense right
P because he beat a uh uh uh who's the
tall guy that he beat up Israel [__]
which we saw in Miami by the way by
that's coming up in March I'm sure we're
we're all
aware listen here's what I do know about
the UFC what goes up must come down
don't get too used to whoever's on the
top there's a good chance he loses this
fight I've never even heard of drus
Theus what what I do know is no guy in
the UFC stays on top that long no name
one I I don't know but this this this is
going to be a fantastic except if your
name is Jon Jones He the only guy yeah
khabib too and those two yeah khabib and
Jon Jones yeah
Jon Jones has one loss but it's because
he was elbowing the guy so bad that it
was a technical loss cuz he tore the guy
face off off cuz he said something about
his Deb no no no it was nothing about
that that was a different story okay all
right next story here so uh Nikki Haley
under pressure from donors to defeat
Donald Trump in New Hampshire after Iowa
caucus loss let me read this full story
to it's on page seven if you want to go
to it uh okay here we go former United
Ambassador Nick Al is facing pressure
from some of the top donors fundraisers
to either seriously compete with or out
outright defeat Donald Trump in the next
week's New Hampshire primary after
finishing third on Monday in the Iowa
caucus I would still like to see her get
somewhere but the mountain she has to
climb is enormous Andy sa been a New
York businessman and Haley's fundraiser
told CNBC Haley's fundraiser by the way
as much as I like Haley I don't even
know what Trump could do to stop himself
right now Sabin
plans to help raise money for Trump if
Haley doesn't make it through the Prime
oh did you hear that Tom Sabin plans to
help raise money for Trump if Haley
doesn't make it through the primary
season despite previously telling CMC he
wouldn't give the former president an
effan nickel he may be the only choice I
have said Sabin she needs to win or a
very very close second place said a
lobbyist who is raising money for Haley
Tom the numbers are out so St anel
nobody hears that name until it's time
for uh uh the New Hampshire primary
because they usually give their their
school in their stage to the debate so
you'll hear about that they also run one
of the better polls in New Hampshire so
rer politics is out there and I you know
I'm sorry I got to call this out I'm
going to make an enemy here but real
clear politics likes to take like the
last five polls and average them as as
if they're all different it's like
taking five UFC fighters and averaging
them you can't one's a Grappler one's a
fighter one's a puncher one's a kick you
know what I mean Pat you can't average
it yet Real Clear Politics makes its it
its bones averaging it so they've got
Haley getting closer 46.3 to 34
according to recent New Hampshire no now
with Christi out suffk and St Anon went
out and did a poll it's 52 for Trump on
suffect 50 for Trump on St anel and
Haley at 36 or 38 on a good day and
DeSantis well the Dan santis voters are
going to come Nikki's way because they
can smell blood in water okay well he's
got like 5.2% in either poll so the
point is here she is hell and gone from
winning this thing and the only reason
she's going to be second is she's the
last person standing so what we have
here is everybody sees the reality now
the deals are being made in the back
rooms it's all been set as soon as
Nikki's done with um New Hampshire Pat
and she's going to lose this thing by
1415 points she's going to lose and then
she's looking at New Hampshire excuse me
South Carolina her home state that she's
woefully behind in her home state and
even if you clear any of the Christie
support in South Carolina which was
negligible you know Christie didn't
campaign there apparently were no free
buffets and and then you take Dan santis
who didn't do well there even though
he's a southern Governor you still have
her light years behind Trump in South
Carolina so everybody's looking at it
and saying okay okay okay we got to stop
here all of the Mayes is over all of the
hope is done hope is dead Mayes are
almost dead so what are we doing here
and the answer is we have one choice the
election matters what do I got to do and
what do you have Andy Sabin saying you
know what as much as I like her it's
time to get serious about who's going to
win this election it's now no longer
about your primary candidate it's about
winning and the drapes are slowly
closing on the stage and that's where we
are so all of this hope about Nikki
Haley aren't looking at things and even
real clear politics out there publishing
these averages that aren't correct you
know the last two ones there we can see
what's happening it's going to be a
15-point victory in New Hampshire
absolutely and she'll be second place 13
to 15 she'll be second place cuz
everybody else is
dead everybody else is gone they've
either pulled out or they're like the
sanos who put all of his marbles in in
Iowa so so you think you think uh uh I
don't know man I mean at this point what
like if I'm a money guy you I'm like the
main money guy I'm like hey the santis
Hal what are you guys doing can we just
stop serly stop this this is not even a
race anymore you're smart you have money
what are you doing giving your money to
a to a campaign that is not going to win
yeah it's like it's like betting on a
horse with with one leg broken you're
like what what am I doing what was that
Rocky 3 where his uh trainer Burgess
Meredith can't stand the see it and he
doesn't want him to get really hurt and
he actually throws in the towel he
didn't want to do it he thought Rocky
had a chance that's where we are it's
over yep look uh we're going to be
hearing the following names for the next
week or two and then we're not going to
hear them anymore the one first one is
Ron de santis after he plac his third in
New Hampshire his campaign is done so
Ron uh continue to do a good job here in
Florida we'll support you here in
Florida you're not going to be our next
president I'm sorry sir uh Nikki Haley
you've got a probably two more weeks
you're going to do your thing in
Hampshire you're going to come in second
all right you're going to waste a lot of
money then you're going to go to South
Carolina and still lose in your home
state and then eventually all the
uh everyone of the media is going to
realize that Donald Trump is going to be
the nominee and there's a a path between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden we all see
how that's going to go and even Bill
Amman who basically said listen you know
he's funding uh Dean Phillips up in
Minnesota because he's realizing holy
[__] guys what is happening we're about
to wheelchair sleepy Joe Biden into
this election versus Donald Trump and
again guys things have changed in the
last four to8 years that's the whole
point so um I think that Trump is going
to be the runaway Victor here I think
that Haley's got a couple weeks left Ron
thank you for your service uh and VC
thank you for all you've done to
basically bring awareness to all the
disruption that's going on in the world
but this is all fun this is all fodder
but we're about to see this play out
Donald Trump is going to be your nomin
I'm just with all that being said I just
when I see Biden and I've been seeing
Kamala just cackling absolutely zero
zero zero substance from whenever she
talks they are way too calm for a party
that's just it's blatantly obvious that
they're losing but they're way too calm
as if they're comfortable basically they
know something they're basically the
orchestra on the Titanic just being like
and the ship is but pat pat I watch it I
listen to every single thing that he
says I've been watch she she's been
making a couple of rounds right now they
are so happy and relaxed it's as if
they're like guys we're good we already
they already have their plans already
said if you guys don't think the left
the Democrats you what you don't you
don't think there's no way I'm just I'm
just I'm addressing your thing there's
no way sitting there's sitting around in
reality I know like it's a great skit I
we should probably do something like
that in reality no one's sitting around
being
like we got this thing we just saw
Donald Trump basically have the biggest
uh victory in Iowa we have we're hearing
stories about Obama sitting down with
Biden's team being like uh guys uh this
ain't looking so good here guys every
story we hear coming out of the White
House is the opposite of that narrative
they're basically like we're in big
trouble here now if we want to go down
that route if they're going to pull some
some rabbit out of the Hat the DNC is
way more powerful and wa have their [__]
way more together than the RNC okay
Ronda Rousey or Ronda McDaniel whoever
whoever's leading the Brigade over there
they can't get their stuff together we
know that there's an anti-establishment
there's establishment Wing in the
Republican party we get that the DNC has
their stuff together but don't mistake
it they're very nervous about Biden and
they know that he's a very weak
candidate and they're going to do
anything they can to prop him up
whatever that means but they are not
sitting I don't I don't think they're
nervous about I don't think that they're
nervous at all because whatever they're
going to do the the Trump trying to keep
Trump off the ballot thing they're
realizing none of it's none of that's
going to work but guess what they have
plan a they have plan B they have plan C
none of it's going to be by accident and
they do they have a chart of what
they're going to do they have like an aa
oh yeah but this AA it's going to come
down to what's going to be the thing
this is my thing cuz mind you when it
was 2020 besides the FBI at Twitter
stopping all the stories what were the
odds that this crazy virus leaked from
this place and they're already talking
about another one from a country that we
can't even talk about you couldn't even
say China without being racist so what
I'm saying is they look way too
comfortable for me in my eyes as if they
already know Biden knows he's not going
to do it bro there's no there's no way
Joe Biden can actually go up on the
stage right now and debate with Donald
Trump there's absolutely he would what
what can he say cuz all the [__] that he
says right now that nobody checks him on
that nobody refutes him if he talks
about the Biden nomics he's crushed if
he wants to win Biden he's going to have
to get up on stage if he doesn't show up
to debates that is the nail in the
coffin for his campaign there's 100% if
he is the candidate 100% chance that
he's going to have to debate if not like
Trump we all understand that he took
some criticism especially Nicki and
Nikki and Des santis are not showing up
on the on the JV debate stage yeah but
there's never been a debate a
presidential election without an actual
debate that' be a horrible look for
Biden Tom this presidential campaign on
both sides there are only a few dates
left and they're not the date of these
next two primaries everybody talked
about it everybody's pulling their money
back all that the next date is February
8th that is the date that the Supreme
Court will hear the arguments against uh
the Colorado Supreme Court to be
overturned on keeping him off the ballot
the next date after that will be around
February 22nd where the Supreme Court
decision will come
down there are three Trump appointed
Supreme Court Justices and Clarence
Thomas that's four in the bag ladies and
gentlemen all you need is John Roberts
you don't even need one more and you
have one more in your pocket all you
need is that and that is a 54 decision
at minimum and I think it's going to be
72 that says you can't take him off the
ballot you can't do that so that way
that clears Maine that clears Colorado
there's your next date now that's
straight to the convention the next date
will be August 20th or 21st in Chicago
Illinois where the superdelegates will
shift and they will move Biden off the
ballot and they will put either Gavin
Newsome or Michelle Obama on the ballot
that's there's your dates guys february8
feary 22 august2 we're not saying like
it's back Adam by the way if you get all
the way down
my opinion is my opinion is everyone's
been saying like Michelle Obama she's
going to be the next president
she's we've seen we've seen no
indication that they're taking Biden off
the B they why would they show their
hand this early Adam then let's back up
February 8th is a done deal date
February 22nd is a done deal limit on
Supreme Court giving a a deliberated
decision that's going to happen August
20th and 21st is the day of the
democratic convention if option one they
walk out with Biden and Kamala this
thing's over if they're going to make a
change that's where they make the change
so I think that's way too late to make a
change it's talking about two months
before the election I'm they got to do
it now if they're going to do anything
how long are we going to speculate and
speculate and speculate and speculate
and speculate what you they're
running into the ground whatever it is
guys until you actually see something
happen it's Biden and kamla Harris about
to get trounced by Trump and whoever he
they're biing their time they know what
that's my point if they walk out of the
convention August 2021 I think the
election's over and I'm telling you
right and we talked about Trump's VP and
I apologize I did call out Sarah HBY I
was making a distinction I said if Trump
has that option of who to pick he's
gonna pick a pretty woman like a Christy
Noam and I was being hyperbolic about
Sarah Huckaby that's all it was okay
that's all I was saying and guess what
I'm saying so Tom the date the February
22nd date that you wrot down that's the
day that honor by February 8th is in
stone this Supreme Court will hear the
oral arguments they'll it deci and then
it's usually 14 days on or by okay and
I'm just FYI if these cheating you know
what actually go through with it which
it doesn't look like it is God willing
it doesn't that end of February can turn
into a very very ugly end of the month
if the Americans real American Patriots
are not going to be happy that the left
what's it called election interfering
what they're doing cheating goes through
it's not going to be it's not going to
be good bro Americans are not going to
be happy I don't know how you speculate
that three justices appointed by Trump
and Clarence Thomas and John Roberts
that's 54 you know that's oh that is
fact that's not speculation speculation
if those people if those people support
the Colorado and remember the Colorado
Supreme Court was a thin decision it was
54 and there were three people on the no
two two that were in the four that
basically wrote a dissenting opinion
that basically started with the words
what the hell are you talking about the
dissenting opinion in on that 54
decision for Colorado Supreme Court
could not have been stronger it's like
what the hell are we doing here but it
was an activist decision it's going down
and that gives him a clear run all the
way to the to the uh to the convention
for Trump he's the guy it's just a
matter of who's his VP going to be
that's all there is on that side don't
forget what we learned from Alina Haba
she's like this is all getting thrown
out Trump's lawyer so we'll see what
happens and I truly believe that they
should not determine who wins the game
in the pregame let them play the game
that's why let's go to The Last Story we
got the LA you're funny let's go let's
go to The Last Story here before we wrap
up do we do Russia Iran China making
moves for World War III do we do white
black Hispanic asian-americans all back
death of Dei poll do you want to do that
one let's go through that one let's go
let's go us go local for the
listeners what does that mean like the
Dei rather than playing Out World War 3
all right let's do that white black
Hispanic and Asian Americans all back
death of Dei and there's a poll that
just came out here let's go through it
Rob if you want to pull this up I love
this okay here we
go so a Galla poll conducted in 2023
revealed that 68% of us adults view the
Supreme Court's decision to eliminate
race as a factor in college admissions
as mostly good thing this sentiment
transcends ethnic background grounds
with substantial support from Asian
white Hispanic and even black Americans
among black respondents 52% considered
the ruling a positive development
highlighting widespread approval the
survey reflects the ongoing debate
surrounding diversity equity and
inclusion Dei initiatives in the United
States billionaire Elon Musk has vocally
criticized Dei saying that Dei Must Die
due to concerns of Reverse Racism Tik
Tok has become a platform for younger
Americans to voice their opinions on
diversity targets while conservative
activists are advocating to for the
removal of programs that provide
advantages to minorities in a private
sector Tom I I I I look at things on
this and I think underneath the surface
there is a sensibility in All American
citizens of all colors not among all of
them but I think that there I believe
that there is a just like the survey
shows that a percent of Asians percent
of Hispanics percent of
African-Americans or black Americans I
don't mean to to label you one way or
the other I know some of you want to be
called one or the other I'm just saying
all people color I believe there's
sensibilities under there and I think
they're seeing it like this I think they
see things like and I'll give you an
example Harvard's in the news so we'll
bring up Harvard when they take students
and they say hey because of your color
you can get into Harvard and here's a
little bit of financial aid and they're
not really ready for Harvard
unfortunately tragically because of the
school systems but they give them an
on-ramp there and then they go get
student loans and then they drop out of
Harvard who do you help you help nobody
because that person of color is now
sitting there with with debt that
they've got yo you're giving you a
privilege and we're bragging about it
but these things happen those things are
happening all over the place and I think
there's sensibilities that are in the
average American we should give the
average American of all colors a little
credit here because beyond the
screeching and screaming that happens on
cable news networks led by a certain
bespectacled woman on
MSNBC they are sitting there with with
some sensibilities under it beyond the
screaming and the yelling this gives me
hope that that for America and it gives
me hope that people's voices are being
heard because there's a lot of wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
happening among people of color who do
not universally support what has been
the scourge of Dei Adam uh well look
sometimes you got to scratch beneath the
surface to see what's really going on so
we've learned that during the BLM riots
it's like a black Liv matter of course
they do well who's not saying that when
you peel back the curtain well it turns
out they're a communist Marxist
basically scam artist same thing that's
going on with Gaza when you start asking
people what's going on there they're
like oh what I didn't realize what this
uh socialist antia it oh I didn't know
same thing that's going on with Dei I
fully agree that Dei must die and what
it sounds like on the surface diversity
Equity inclusion that's great same thing
with ESG economic uh envi environmental
social it all sounds great when you look
in the details the devil's always in the
details it's like yeah I don't know
about all this inertive action stuff I
don't know about this judging everything
about race I don't know about the fact
that in the Fortune 100 companies they
only hired 6% of their employees who are
white even though 60% of Americans are
white uh something don't add here so
it's very encouraging here to see that
black white yellow brown Puerto Rican
and Haitian all my friends from the Zulu
Nation everyone's basically realizing
that Dei must die so what we learned
also is that the pendulum swings from
the left to the right and the reversion
to the meme is the equilibrium and I'll
say one thing and I want to give a shout
out to one person VC ramaswami this guy
if there's anything that I remember from
his entire campaign is just harping on
the woke and the Dei and the ESG he was
amazing at that and you saw the joke
that the Babylon be just did about VC
Rob pull that up it's just it's it's
hilarious good but this guy is an
absolute Beast probably one of the
smartest guys we've ever set down set
down with I said that he's the Andrew
Tate of politics disruptor gifted
speaker you might not agree with them
you may agree with them but you can't
look away the guy's an absolute Beast
Babylon B basically made a joke about
him being Indian 7-Eleven one of the
things I believe you know I'm getting a
racist epithet these days it's not
racist if you make fun of everybody if
you single out one group and one group
only but any group can get it I make fun
of Jewish people Catholic people Muslim
people everything so here's the Babylon
B making fun of I mean that's just funny
bro Trump promises VC an Administration
position running the White House
7-Eleven that's okay that's funny the
reason that's funny is because this guy
could literally have any job in the
administration that's how gifted he is
so fun it's a joke it's a satire and I
guarantee you someone like VC is going
to take it and try and be like haha
funny funny go [__] yourself all right
can I go count my billions of dollars
that I'm going to get you know after
this thing so Vex a beast I think Dei
should die and that's my final thought
and and I and here's the thing when it
comes to the Dei I'm so happy that
people of all Races are waking up it if
it like I said if it's Starbucks and
you're like we have to hire a certain
amount F fine go do it but when you have
when real life decisions and real lives
are at stake I have a problem when Joe
Biden says I'm just the my back
president is just going to be a a black
woman a woman of color it's like you I
want the best person that's qualified
for the job so when you have somebody
going I don't care I'm only going to
hire this race or when you have United
saying I want crazy bastards eating
crayons flying our place that are gay
and they're like like what do we and
like or Supreme Court says I want the
best person at the job and that is
it to to wrap up here when I saw that
story uh of Babylon B I thought it was
just appropriate to make a stop go just
go ahead oh you're so go ahead see this
is a dream when you make money you get
to afford to buy some high-end type of
food it's more highend than hot dogs at
7-Eleven I mean I I just thought it was
appropri you want to go for lunch
7-Eleven how you feeling Eric my friend
rebecc look
at good look look look you know oh my
God you got to eat one of those per year
man it's just insane anyways all right
so end of the podcast Vinnie give us the
final uh uh verdict on M before we wrap
it up first of all guys I love you I've
had at least 20 while I've been in here
I love you guys keep them coming cuz
we're almost at 500 I said I'd give a 10
shout out Jane stanridge Jane I also
want to give her sh she gave you five in
a row she gave me she gave Tom guys if
you haven't been on this she asked me
one question Tom stay out of this shut
up all right no she asked me one
question I'm giving five Vinnie is that
the right way tomorrow because me and
Jane are getting married running away
together I said I'd give you guys a
shout out you said about her last
Michelle Medina Ricardo F Jonathan
Schneider armman uh how do you say that
last name p Armenian Hammer Armen K
makan good that's that's my boy Russell
Samy side Brian Adams Lee Little Nick
kinich and Christopher Gibson I
appreciate you guys guys man me we're
almost where we at where the numbers at
Pat you are you're up there man you're
you're uh uh I don't know the exact I
think you flipped it is it flip I was I
wrote it somewhere around here but
anyways we're going to wrap up you're
getting closer to 500 but by the way Tom
also got a lot of mans while on the
podcast today so did Adam so if you want
to support Adam go and man with Adam as
well can I read my names or only we're
going to wrap up we're going to wrap up
we're going to W is rigged tomorrow what
time tomorrow here what time tomorrow 3
p.m. tomorrow 3 p.m. with Glen Beck
tomorrow 3 p.m. I'm all right take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye